- Alright, here we are in the future.
I'm Keith, the Electric Daredevil,
ready to try the hourglass.
(lively music)
- Okay, alright, alright, alright.
Whoa!
Oh, no.
(screaming)
- And then over here.
Nope.
Okay, yup.
- Now what am I supposed to
do with this, go forward?
(laughing)
Welcome to the future,
it's very terrifying.
Whoa!
- [Voiceover] I can't go forward.
I'm stuck.
- [Voiceover] Oh, well I'm spinning.
If the goal is to spin,
I figured that one out.
- Alright, gotta do this.
That actually is working.
- [Voiceover] Is this supposed to go fast?
One small step for man, one
giant step for Ashley kind.
- I feel like, to really go
forward the way I want to,
I just have to look solemn.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I know
you're mad, I'm mad too.
(laughing)
(screaming)
- Stop, stop!
- [Voiceover] I'm so sad.
Just the saddest man on this tiny,
portable, lateral skateboard.
- Yeah, I got this now.
I feel pretty confident on it.
I don't like the uneven terrain...
Oh no, can't slow down.
- No way, hold on.
I can't get out of...
What's happening?
- I used to live in New York,
and walking fucking sucked,
if I had one of these,
dang you give me those 20
blocks and I will board.
Oh, I'm turning, I'm turning, I'm turning.
- I feel good, I feel proud
of myself that I was able
to make it to the gate and
back without falling off.
It probably took me a lot
longer than other people,
but hey I did it.
I also feel really old.
- For me, the positive is
when you have one of these
everybody knows you got money.
- It's like I was trying to
hold on to a tree with my legs
the whole time, except the
tree was moving around.
- So, I feel really cool.
I feel a little bit
connected to today's youth.
Hello youths, I feel connected to you.
Maybe next time you guys will invite me
to sit with you at lunch, or not.
Cool.
- They're gonna have to
make new laws about this.
Can I play with it a little more?
This is cool!
I also like being the best at it.
Does it go up hills?